this visit by Iranian president
ibrahimovici tunicaragua is expected to
deepen cooperation with a country also
sanctioned by the United States while
discussions are expected to cover
political economic and trade agreements
worth tens of billions of dollars the
leaders have used the visit to criticize
the U.S and European nations calling
them common enemies
all of them without exception are major
robbers and exploiters of the people in
different regions of the earth and the
truth is that this practice has not
disappeared
it's a rare trip for aec who began a
tour of Latin America this week with a
visit to Venezuela Tehran is one of the
most important allies for president
Nicolas maduro's government
we are friends of difficult times to the
people and governments of Venezuela the
relationship between Iran and Venezuela
is not a normal diplomatic relationship
but is a strategic relationship between
two countries that have common interests
common visions and common enemies
Venezuela has some of the world's
largest oil reserves in both countries
are opic members the oil cartel has
become Central to discussions of the
energy crisis sparked by Russia's war on
Ukraine the conflicts renewed Global
efforts to solve Venezuela's political
and economic crisis
Maduro visited Iran a year ago signing a
20-year pact to increase cooperation in
the oil petrochemical and defense
sectors
races 12 Allied nations in Latin America
comes as tensions with the U.S are
worsening the U.S has accused Iran of
providing Russia with materials to build
a plant to make drones but Iran says it
supplied drones to Russia before the
start of the war
isi will complete his tour with a visit
to Cuba and is expected to hold more
talks on what he says are changes needed
to build a new world order
[Applause]